back to las vegas now if you are a
hockey lover and a cookie lover listen
up because we have the perfect combo of
the two pucks cookies and treats is now
open at the district and we have the
owner jenny lynn eddington here with us
today hi jenny how are you good i'm
great i am so excited to talk about
sweets but i really want to talk about
the story behind pucks and how you came
up with the idea
so i at um like a lot of people oops
i might just have to eat it a lot of
people in las vegas and southern nevada
i wasn't a hockey fan until the gold
knights came in right and then um their
first year i mean we saw miracle after
miracle after miracle and it just kind
of really took this this city by storm i
don't know if the players know how much
of impact they made on this city but i
am like golden knights fan through and
through didn't wasn't a fan before
golden knights and now i'm just like a
die-hard but one of the things that that
i think everybody whether you're a
hockey fan or not they really unify this
community and it's kind of hard
sometimes i think to feel like you like
you can it's hard to find your people
sometimes because it's a very transient
city and now it's like you know who's a
local because they've got vjk everything
and um it's just it's given the city
something to really fight for and so
that really resonated with me i'm a home
baker i've always dreamed of opening up
a cookie concept and so um
i just decided hey now's the time i'm
going to do it and here we are all of
our cookies are shaped
like a hockey puck i was going to say
this is not your average little cookie
this is a good thick cookie it looks
like a hockey puck and you have some
other fun creative things on the menu
too i can't stop looking away what is
this so this this is
if you come into the store
you can get a warm cookie with ice cream
we need a clothes
look how good this is
i'm actually making what's called a hat
trick okay and if you know
hockey
a hat trick is is three pucks three
pucks in the goal so this is cookie ice
cream
cookie it's sliding i don't like
you know on ice that's very very on
brand it's been sitting here for a
little bit um but yeah our
a lot of people come in for a puck drop
which is just a cookie warm cookie with
a scoop of ice cream
or i mean i have teenagers that will
take a hat trick down in no time i was
gonna say this you need to share but i
bet there's some people out there it's
all just looking so good i'm going in at
least yes
delicious what else you have on the menu
and what can people you know different
flavors and order when they come in so
we have eight cookies on the menu at all
times and there's some that's down the
menu um like the chocolate chip and our
peanut butter cup are super popular
they're always on our menu and then we
do have rotating seasonal flavors
so they they change every month
we also have what's called our barn
burner
a barn burner is a cookie ice cream and
then it's covered in italian marine and
it's yes it is amazing we rotate the
flavor on that as well and then i do
have for gifting um we love gifts and we
we put a lot of uh effort in our in our
packaging people say our our box has
become iconic they're like seeing boxes
yeah these yellow boxes uh you know
taking over the city but um these tubes
are really fun you can stack cookies um
in them and give them to your friends
our real estate
friends love these and we do catering
orders so we love to cater parties and
um bring the puck to your house we bring
pucks to your house oh that's so fun you
have a little bit of everything and i
just was eyeing this sprinkle cookie
here so you can do a variety this would
be the perfect gift for me so if
anyone's looking this is what i want
thank you so much congratulations on
everything thank you to the golden
knights for inspiring our community and
bringing about businesses just like
yours and go check her out at the
district she's been open for a month we
got a support i'm gonna take a bite and
set it to break we'll see you guys on
the other side